let's go to five headlines
[Music]
before we get to the headlines here you
know the rnc is uh we're talking about
the rnc just a second but it's off to a
pretty good start this week blowing the
dc dnc out of the water in almost every
way especially when it comes to ratings
in fact reports of monday night's
c-span viewership are six times the
opening night of the dnc
um which is pretty uh pretty astounding
not very surprising though
given what i was forced to watch last
week i guess i'm not i'm not too
surprised to see it
daily wire is uh matching this
enthusiasm with an even better lineup of
all access live to watch the rnc with
you at dailywire.com
uh starting today at 8 15 eastern 5 15
pacific i will be live streaming the
entire night of rnc speakers
and watching with you uh taking your
questions and your comments
and telling you authoritatively not just
what i think but also what you should
think
about this don't don't think for
yourself okay let me do the thinking for
you
that's remember i'm the theocratic
fascist dictator that's the way this is
supposed to work
uh and we'll be hosting more live watch
parties every day for the rest of the
week so don't miss out all access
members get to join uh all access live
sessions where
one of us hopes hosts hop on every night
to uh chat with you both in live stream
and in the comments
so go to dailywire.com walsh right now
to get 20
off all access with coupon code access
dailywire.com walsh coupon code access
20
off go there now okay
so number one uh uh number one is day
two of the rnc convention last night as
just mentioned
you won't be surprised to learn that my
favorite moment was a speech
uh not from a non not from a politician
because my theory that politicians never
give interesting speeches
ever has been in my opinion confirmed
by both conventions but luckily there's
been some non-political speeches that i
thought were pretty good
nick sandman the the kid who was
slandered by cnn
and other media companies and sued them
and forced them to settle the lawsuits
he spoke for several minutes uh he had a
lot to say that was quite relevant and
important but
i'm going to play just a clip of him
giving his side of the story
describing from his perspective what
happened on that
fateful day in dc watch this
my name is nick sandman and i'm the
teenager who was defamed by the media
after an encounter with a group of
protesters on the steps of the lincoln
memorial last year
before i begin i'd like to thank
president trump for the opportunity to
share some of my story
and why it matters so much to this
november's election
in 2019 i attended the march for life in
washington dc
where i demonstrated in defense of the
unborn
later that day i bought a make america
great again hat
because our president donald trump has
distinguished himself as one of the most
pro-life presidents
in the history of our country and i
wanted to express my support for him too
looking back now how could i possibly
imagine
that the simple act of putting on that
red hat
would unleash hate from the left and
make myself the target of network
and cable news networks nationwide being
from kentucky
the birthplace of abraham lincoln my
classmates and i visited the lincoln
memorial
i found myself face to face with nathan
phillips
and other professional protesters
looking to turn me
into the latest poster child showing why
trump is bad well the media portrayed me
as an aggressor
with a relentless smirk on my face
in reality the video confirms i was
standing with my hands behind my back
and an awkward smile on my face that had
two thoughts
one don't do anything that might further
agitate the man banging a drum in my
face
and two i was trying to follow a family
friend's advice
never to do anything to embarrass your
family your school
or your community before i knew what was
happening it was over
one of mr phillips fellow agitators
yelled out
we got him it's all right here on video
and we won grandpa so yeah and then he
goes on to talk about cancel culture and
how it's
you know wielded by the media and the
left to destroy people they don't like a
very effective speech all around i mean
this is a guy you want to talk about
victims of the cancel culture this is
this is
one of the classic examples of it a very
as i said effective and
and the best part is the media just
absolutely hated it
uh this was playing on cnn which is
great
they were just really mad salty as the
kids would say and so they lashed out
again just spewing vitriol
at this kid many examples i could show
but let's just go with this one joe
lockhart is a cnn contributor
and he is i think very jealous that nick
sandman gets paid more from cnn than he
does
so he tweeted this i'm watching tonight
because it's important but i don't have
to watch this snot-nosed
entitled kid from kentucky talking about
salmon uh
snot-nosed entitled kid from kentucky is
what he calls him
right well joe you know better to be a
snot-nosed entitled
kid than a snot-nosed entitled old fart
like you i mean if you have to choose
between the two that i mean that's
really the time to be snot-nosed and
entitled
as a kid we we all were um but you know
your
what in your 50s 60s now and and you
still are and the thing is
yes nick is entitled he actually is
some people are entitled to certain
things he actually is entitled
to not be slandered and libeled right
he's legally entitled to that and so if
he's coming off as entitled
that's because he has a certain
entitlement a real legal entitlement
that is protection from libel and
slander that was infringed
and that's why now cnn is entitled to
pay him
for that that's how it works uh okay
number two
big news here new evidence was filed in
the george floyd case
it's a document from the hennepin county
medical examiner
dr andrew baker and
let me read this document to you in full
here's what it says a short document
filed in court it says on may 31 2020 at
7 30 pm assistant hennepin county
attorney patrick lofton and i met with
dr andrew baker
on microsoft teams all three of us were
at different locations dr baker said
that he had
and recently received the final
toxicology results from
mr george floyd's samples which were
analyzed by nms
labs ab shared his screen and showed us
the results he said that there
that where it says hospital blood those
samples are from mr floyd's hospital
admissions and we're not acquired
as autopsy a b said that these samples
are better for determining actual blood
toxicity than samples taken at the
autopsy samples taken out autopsy it may
have undergone post-mortem distribution
uh whatever that means a b walked us
down the list of substances for which
nms labs tested those values he
highlighted were
4 a n pp a precursor and
metabolite of fentanyl present in mr
floyd's blood
methamphetamine which he describes as
very near the low end and a stimulant
hard on the heart
uh fentanyl he said that's pretty high
this level of fentanyl can cause
pulmonary edema
mr floyd's lungs were two to three times
their normal weighted autopsy that's a
fatal level of fentanyl under normal
circumstances
and then nor fentanyl uh a metabolite of
fentanyl
mr floyd's urine was tested for four
things and are redundant
um abe said that if mr floyd had been
found dead in his home or anywhere else
and there were no other contributing
factors he would conclude
that it was an overdose death okay
so he had a level of fentanyl system
that's fatal under normal circumstances
uh and under normal circumstances he
would have been ruled in overdose
these seem like important details now
you could say
well this is not in normal circumstances
the arrest the knee on the neck
contributed to it yes but it's hard to
see how you sustain a murder charge
when a person has potentially fatal
levels of a toxin in their body which
they themselves
willingly ingested so more details in
that case that are that are interesting
number three the indie star reports
eight elementary school teachers who
were shot with airsoft guns
execution style during an active shooter
training drill last year
are suing the sheriff's department that
conducted the training the controversial
training drill conducted at meadowland
elementary school in northern indiana
last year became national news after
teachers
reported being left bruised bloodied and
traumatized
the lawsuit filed last week in indiana's
northern federal court
claims that for white county sheriff
white county sheriff's deputies should
subject to teachers
to verbal threats exploitism screaming
in addition to being struck with plastic
pellets fired from airsoft guns
the teachers displayed obvious signs of
anguish and physical pain
but were humiliated to find the law
enforcement officers joking and laughing
at them
the complaint says the terrifying and
inexplicable experience left the
teachers with lasting physical and
emotional injuries
let's see and then it goes on a first
grade teacher was diagnosed with ptsd
after this
uh continues it says eight teachers out
of approximately 35 that were present
have signed the lawsuit um
according to the complaint the teachers
were broken up into small groups and
told by sheriff's deputies to line up
facing a wall and kneel
once they were kneeling an officer shot
the teachers across the backs
why what was the point of this they were
not told to tell the other teacher they
were told not to tell the other teachers
waiting in another room for their turn
and uh later in the day teachers were
also subject to a series of drills
in which they were instructed at
different times to hide in classrooms to
try and bear create doors
and to throw tennis balls at the
officers during each drill officers shot
the teachers with airsoft guns according
to the complaint
then it goes on physical and emotional
injuries
according to the complaint the teachers
experienced several
severe well it says several emotional
distress i'm pretty sure it means to say
severe emotional distress okay all right
now a few points here not to laugh at
their emotional distress
uh which i am a little bit this whole
scene just seems
completely outlandish first of all to
say you have ptsd from being shot with a
pellet gun
is absurd i'm sorry i i've been shot
with a pellet gun in my day many times
and really doesn't hurt that much um
and you know as long as you don't take a
pellet to the eye or anything that could
cause problems
so all of this whining about emotional
distress is
obviously ridiculous and just a bit of
theater from teachers who are looking
for a payday
second you know and as aside from all
that i've never quite understood even if
there's
if there is real emotional distress how
do you
quantify that in in terms of money
how do you put a certain dollar amount
on emotional well i i have 50 million
dollars worth of emotional distress i
think 50 million dollars
would heal this this these my emotional
problems
40 million won't do it you know 55
million i don't need no just right there
50 million that's what i need
i've looked within myself and
[Music]
realized that 50 million is what will
heal me that's never quite made sense to
me but
second um these active shooter drills
are also
completely ridiculous it just seems like
a really macabre
adult version of cops and robbers
it's fantasy role play in the guise of
safety training is what it is
the whole thing is a waste of time and
resources um
the you know why do the teachers need to
act out
being executed like
what do you need practice for that um
and why do the cops need practice doing
it that's a little bit disturbing too
so the whole thing is just is always the
the chances that
a particular school will actually
be the victim of a mass school shooting
is is so
vanishingly small that you can't
possibly justify the amount of time and
energy and resources put into stuff like
this
even if you know these kinds of drills
were effective which i don't think they
are at all
but um now that doesn't mean that
schools shouldn't have policies in place
and ways to protect themselves i'm just
saying that acting out
these role play games like they're at
boot camp you know
training to be to invade some middle
eastern country or something
is i think totally ludicrous and besides
you know you can give the instructions
and tell people what to do
without shooting them with airsoft guns
when you do a fire drill
you don't actually like burn people you
know you don't
when you do the fire drill do you light
candles and then chase
the kids down the hallway and like start
singing their elbows
while they're running no um all you have
to do is just tell them okay this is
what we do here's here in case this
thing hap
probably won't happen but if it does
this is what we do
okay thanks now i know we could go about
our day and besides the training goes
out the window anyway once the bullets
start flying
but most people who are not professional
you know professional law enforcement
professional in the military whatever
once the bullets fly they're just going
to panic anyway and do whatever seems
the most appropriate in that situation
so
even if the scenario you act out
actually happens your little staged
production probably won't do any good
and really when it comes down to it
if there's a shooter going around
executing people
room by room you you can either
try to get out of the building or
if you have a gun to protect yourselves
you can use that which i which i think
would be great
if schools were able to actually protect
themselves in that way but if you're in
the room
and you have no gun and
you haven't left and the shooter comes
in
and you know you're literally backed
into a corner and he's the only one
armed
um i i just don't know that there's any
real strategy you can have in place
that's going to prevent horrible things
from happening and certainly throwing
tennis balls at him
isn't going to do anything okay let's go
to number four don lemon of cnn is
finally
finally speaking out against the rioting
only took him about three months
but finally he has he's finally realized
that it's a problem
it's just it's not a problem in the way
that you probably think it's a problem
listen to this
i do think that uh this what you said
what's happening in kenosha is a
rorschach test
for the entire country and i think this
is a blind spot
for democrats i think democrats are
ignoring this problem or hoping that it
will go away
and it's not going to go away and so
unless someone comes up with a solution
over the next
73 days or 70 so however many days
68 days 68 days so it's not gonna the
problem is not gonna be
fixed by then but what they can do
and i think maybe joe biden may be
afraid to do it
i'm not sure maybe he won't maybe he is
he's got to address it
he's got to come out and talk about it
he's got to do a speech like barack
obama did about race
he's got to come out and tell people
that he is going to deal with the issue
of police reform in this country and
that what's happening now is happening
under donald trump's watch
and on donald trump's watch and when he
is the president kamala harris is the
vice president
then they will take care of this problem
but guess what
the rioting has to stop chris as you
know
and i know it's showing up in the
polling it's showing up in focus groups
it is the only thing it is the only
thing
right now that is sticking
and the democrats tonight stuck with
that right
and they also stuck with the theme that
you said
the coronavirus you got coronavirus
and you have kenosha okay but you see
the caveat there he's speaking out
because it hurts democrats in the polls
that's what he's worried about he's not
worried about
people's lives livelihood businesses
being destroyed he's worried about
the polls which doesn't surprise me of
course
but it's it is always interesting when
they say that stuff out loud
number five finally uh what we've all
been waiting for really hoping for aaron
rodgers has chimed in
um about the shooting of jacob blake and
you know the social and cultural issues
at play as well
and we can all we can all see the matter
i think more clearly
now that the quarterback of the green
bay packers has expounded on the issue
so we as i said we've all been waiting
for this and uh really glad that he's
here to pass his wisdom along
here's what he had to say i think like
you know like i said in the video and
like we talked about in the video that
we put out there's a
systemic problem and until the problem
is fixed
this is going to be an all too common
sighting in this country it's obviously
it's home
you know being not far from green bay um
i'm not gonna you know comment directly
on the video until
more facts come out but you know
obviously it's
something where you as a as a
non-police officer i think a lot of us
natural question is when
uh is lethal force necessary
and again i think that goes to a
systematic
problem that needs to be addressed at
some point
you know there's antiquated laws that
you know are prejudicial against people
of color in this state
i think the governor and his and the
folks
you know at the capitol need to take a
hard look at some of those
systems that are in place yeah that just
has that has
major major hostage video vibes going on
all of these videos of these athletes
uh like brett favre and you know others
speaking about this
they all have hostage video vibes but
nothing quite like this
you can just imagine masked men with
guns in the background
whispering lines to him say systemic
racism
systemic racism say it uh i mean rogers
is
he's just going through a list of
buzzwords and phrases
that he probably picked up when he
scanned the blm website right before
going in for the press conference
and he's just sitting there like um you
know
the thing is uh there's systemic
underlying patriarchal
cisgendered privilege privilege
uh contributing to uh
inequity and racial
injustice by the way
he says that antiquated laws have
something to do with it he mentions
antiqua
that's another buzz phrase he picked up
the antiquated laws
those antiquated laws are antiquated
i uh uh aaron what does antiquated mean
again
well it just means it means they're
they're very anti just means they're
antiquated that's what it means but
what does that have to do with the jacob
blake shooting what antiquated laws are
we talking about the laws against sexual
assault
that's why there was a warrant for his
arrest i just don't know what laws he's
talking about here that have anything to
do with it well
and he doesn't know either of course
he's just he's just babbling and
hoping that it'll be enough to keep the
mob from coming after him and we'll see
if it does
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content